Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I like an Englishman to look like an Englishman and beards are foreign and breed vermin. Also, depend upon it, they will lead to filthy habits. That was Lord Raglan, who was in command of the British forces in the Crimean War. Famous, wasn't he, Dominic?
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目抢先听，并成为我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我喜欢英国人看起来像个英国人，胡须是外国的东西，还会滋生寄生虫。此外，请相信我，它们会导致恶劣的习惯。那是拉格伦勋爵（Lord Raglan）说的，他是克里米亚战争中英军的统帅。他很有名，对吧，多米尼克？
He'd fought in Napoleonic Wars, and even though the French were allies in the Crimean war, he kept shouting, attack the French. Yes, he did. Now the question is, did he actually say this or is it completely made up by George MacDonald Fraser and inserted in Flashman at the Charge, Flashman, the bully from Tom Brown's school days, whose memoirs are the subject of George Macdonald Fraser's brilliantly entertaining novels. Well, that's a good question, Tom. Hello, everybody. I think even if it is made up, I'm sure he thought it. So that quotation was actually recommended by Sam Brett Jr., who's just been reading Flash from the Charge.
他曾参加过拿破仑战争，尽管法国人在克里米亚战争中是盟友，但他还是不断大喊：进攻法国。是的，他确实这么喊过。现在的问题是，这话真的是他说的，还是完全由乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽（George MacDonald Fraser）虚构出来的？这句话被塞进了《福拉斯曼冲锋》（Flashman at the Charge）里。福拉斯曼是《汤姆·布朗求学记》里的那个恶霸，他的回忆录正是乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽那些极其精彩的娱乐小说的题材。嗯，这是个好问题，汤姆。大家好。我想，即使这是虚构的，我也确信他心里就是这么想的。所以，这段引言实际上是小萨姆·布雷特（Sam Brett Jr.）推荐的，他最近刚刚读完《福拉斯曼冲锋》。
And when he heard we were doing a podcast about beards, he said, oh, Lord Raglan had some very sound views about beards. You should mention them in the episode. And so here we are. And so here we are, yes. This was meant to be the second half of a single quirky one-off. Yes. And it's dead.
当他听说我们要做一个关于胡须的播客时，他说：“哦，拉格伦勋爵对胡须有非常高明的见解。你们应该在这一集里提一下。”所以我们就这样开始了。是的，所以我们就这样开始了。这本该是上下两集里奇趣番外篇的第二部分。是的。而且它已经凉了。
Yeah. Draws on to the crack of doom. this is the story tom of modern beards last time we had classical ancient beards early medieval beards do we have some do we have some high medieval beards we do we move on to early modern we do and actually i have to say uh we've had to record this multiple times and in in fact, I was laughing so much that I destroyed my microphone. So in the last episode, you were making the points
对。拖到了世界末日。汤姆，这就是现代胡须的故事。上一次我们聊了古典时期的古代胡须、早期中世纪的胡须，我们有高盛中世纪的胡须吗？我们有的。我们推进到近代早期了吗？是的。实际上，我得说，呃，我们不得不把这部分录了好多次。事实上，我当时笑得太厉害，把麦克风都笑坏了。所以在上一集里，你提出了
about shaving and godliness. Basically, a clean face means you're kind of the priestly cast, I guess. You're closer to the supernatural, to the divine, right? And a full beard means you're very much of this world.
关于刮胡子与虔诚的观点。基本上，光洁的面孔意味着你是某种僧侣阶层，我想是的。你离超自然的东西、离神圣的东西更近，对吧？而满脸大须则意味着你极其属于这个世界。
Smiting order of man. So the question in my mind was, why don't more people shave? If it's a godly look, why don't people want to look in a highly religious age? Why don't people want to look clean shaven? And there are obvious technical reasons, which you didn't really talk about so much last time. So if you'd wanted to shave what are you shaving with so the razors that people use which could be made of sort of i don't know bronze i guess copper they are like little knives or indeed miniature axes that people use by and large you'd have to either you have a slave or a servant who shaves you, or you have to visit a barber, as you said.
挥舞着刀剑的世俗凡人。所以在我脑海里的问题是，为什么不多一些人刮胡子呢？如果这是一种神圣的外表，为什么人们在极度宗教化的时代里不想这么做？为什么人们不想让自己看起来刮得干干净净的？这里有显而易见的技术原因，你上一次其实没怎么谈到。所以如果你想刮胡子，你是用什么来刮的呢？人们使用的剃须刀——它们可能是某种——我不知道，大概是青铜或铜做的——它们就像小刀，或者实际上是人们普遍使用的小型斧头。要么你得有一个奴隶或仆人帮你刮胡子，要么就像你说的，你得去拜访理发师。
So in medieval England, if you visit a barber, a barber is also a surgeon or a dentist. Is it like in Roman times? Just like in Roman times. Exactly. There's massive continuity there. And barbering is a very serious business. So the Worshipful Company of Barbers was set up in London in 1308. And I mean, this will astound you, Tom. Worshipful Company of Barbers was set up in London in 1308.
所以在中世纪的英国，如果你去拜访理发师，理发师同时也是外科医生或牙医。这就像在罗马时代那样吗？就像在罗马时代一样。这其中有巨大的延续性。而且理发是一项非常严肃的业务。因此，伦敦理发师行会（Worshipful Company of Barbers）于1308年成立。我的意思是，这会让你大吃一惊的，汤姆。伦敦理发师行会于1308年成立。
And I mean, this will astound you, Tom. Guess what the guy who's the first head of the organization was called? What his surname was? Well, I know because you've written it down. Richard Le Barber. Richard Le Barber, yeah. I mean, was that nominative determinism or did he take on that name after deciding to become a barber? I suspect he took on that name, which is disappointing. You'd like to think he'd been born barber. Unless his father, I mean, it was in the
我的意思是，这会让你大吃一惊的，汤姆。你猜这个组织的第一任负责人叫什么名字？他的姓氏是什么？嗯，我知道，因为你已经写下来了。理查德·勒·巴伯（Richard Le Barber）。理查德·勒·巴伯，是的。我的意思是，这是词源决定论（nominative determinism），还是他在决定成为理发师后才改了那个名字？我猜他是改成了那个名字，这挺让人失望的。你本来希望他生来就是个理发师。除非他的父亲，我的意思是，这在
family. Possibly it was in the family. You'd think it would be the kind of thing that would be in the family, wouldn't you? So it got its royal charter from Edward IV in 1462. And part of that was actually a crackdown on unlicensed barbers who are kind of cutting people's hair in an incompetent way, giving them slicing their throat yeah giving them very deep cuts while shaving and it actually is a serious business because as we will see in an age before antibiotics a barbering mishap can kill you and it does kill people or if you run into barbers whose wives makes pies out of you i mean that would also be bad in seville for example no in fleet street odd. Of course. I was being dimwitted. So there are risks everywhere.
家族里代代相传。可能这在家族里代代相传吧。你会觉得这应该是那种会在家族里世代相传的事情，对吧？所以它在1462年得到了爱德华四世颁发的皇家特许状。其中一部分实际上是对无证理发师的打击，这些人以一种不熟练的方式剪头发，给顾客割喉——是的，在刮胡子时给顾客留下很深的伤口。这其实是一件很严肃的事，因为正如我们所见，在没有抗生素的时代，一次理发事故是会要人命的，而且它确实会害死人。或者如果你遇到了妻子会把你做成馅饼的理发师——我的意思是，那也很糟糕。比如在塞维利亚？不，在弗利特街。奇怪。我刚才太糊涂了。所以到处都是危险。
Yes. There are also all the medical arguments. And the medical arguments, by and large, are very much in favour of beards. So as we talked about last time, since the Greeks, people had believed that beards were vital. They were connected to the production of semen. And both of these things reflected the vital heat of a man. So there's a wonderful book. Are you familiar with this book, Tom? Facial Hair and the Performance of Early Modern Masculinity? No, but I can imagine exactly what it's like.
是的。还有所有的医学论证。这些医学论证大体上都非常支持蓄须。正如我们上次讨论的那样，自古希腊以来，人们就一直认为胡须至关重要。它们与精液的产生息息相关。这两点都反映了一个男人的生命之热（vital heat）。所以有一本精彩的书。汤姆，你熟悉这本书吗？《面部毛发与近代早期男子气概的展演》（Facial Hair and the Performance of Early Modern Masculinity）？不，但我完全能想象它是什么样的。
Yes, by Dr. Eleanor Rycroft. She says, facial hair functioned as evidence of the male capacity to produce semen, because puberty would produce the necessary testicular heat for a boy to become a man and also for smoke to rise in the body and push hair out through your face so the smoke pushes you know the heat makes the hair come out of your face when you're sort of 13 she compares it to menstruation in a girl exactly so and it does sound a bit mad to us but the very very tip-top medical authorities of the day believe this so are you familiar with hildegard of bingen of course yes one of the great figures of medieval
是的，埃莉诺·赖克罗夫特（Eleanor Rycroft）博士写的。她说，面部毛发可以作为男性产生精液能力的证据，因为青春期会产生男孩成长为男人所需的必要睾丸热量，同时也会让体内的“烟气”上升，通过面部把毛发推出来。所以这种烟气会推动——你知道的，当你在13岁左右时，热量会让毛发从脸上长出来。她把它比作女孩的月经。完全是这样。这听起来对我们来说有点疯狂，但当时最顶尖的医学权威们确实是这么认为的。所以，你熟悉宾根的希尔德加德（Hildegard of Bingen）吗？当然，是的。中世纪最伟大的女性圣洁人物之一。
female holiness there you go so she was in the rhineland in the 12th century she's a composer she is the top german to go to about natural history if you like natural history and you like germans you're laughing and she says a lot of this is about your breath. So a very fertile man has very hot breath. But that's clearly true. The moisture of your breath is so hot and so drenched in testosterone, effectively, that the area around your mouth will be very moist and a beard can grow more freely there.
就是这样。所以她在12世纪的莱茵兰活动，她是一位作曲家，如果你喜欢自然历史，而且你又喜欢德国人的话，她是德国自然历史领域的首屈一指的人物。你笑了。她说，这很大程度上与你的呼吸有关。因此，一个极具生育能力的男人，他的呼吸非常炽热。这显然是真的。你呼吸中的湿气是如此炽热，且实际上充满了睾酮，以至于你嘴巴周围的区域会非常湿润，胡须在那里可以更自由地生长。
Fair to point out that she is an abbess. Yeah. She's not an authority. To be honest, she's woman-splaining. Yeah. That's what she's doing. She is indeed. She is indeed.
公平地说，她是一位女修道院院长。是的。她算不上什么权威。老实说，她这是在“女权说教”（woman-splaining）。是的。她就是这么干的。她确实如此。她确实如此。
And we never approve of that on this podcast. And actually, thinking about the Middle Ages more generally, fashion is obviously set by the most powerful. And as in martial periods in the middle ages more generally fashion is obviously set by the most powerful and as in martial periods in the roman empire that we talked about last time so the kind of the crisis periods when there's all the action on the frontiers and you've got all these bulk and strong men with their beards in late medieval europe powerful men have beards by and large so edward iii we talked about great hero of the podcast he has a beard henry iv who we gave high marks to in england he also has a beard henry the eighth
我们在这个播客里从来不赞同这种行为。实际上，更广泛地思考中世纪，时尚显然是由权势最大的人引领的。正如中世纪更广泛的好战时期一样，时尚显然是由权势最大的人引领的。正如我们上次谈到的罗马帝国的军事化时期一样，也就是那些边境战事频繁、充满了身强力壮且留着胡须的猛男的危机时期，在西欧中世纪晚期，权势阶层大体上都是留着胡须的。所以爱德华三世——我们讨论过，他是本播客的伟大英雄——他留着胡须；亨利四世——我们在英格兰给他打了高分——他也留着胡须；亨利八世……
henry the fifth well henry the fifth is the outlier but you remember he's compared to a priest isn't yes by french ambassadors and i'm thinking presumably this is a reflection his religiosity. Yes, it must be. And then if you look abroad in the following century, Charles V, the great monarch of the age, Philip II of Spain, famously bearded. Now, some of this might be,
亨利五世——好吧，亨利五世是个特例，但你还记得他被法国使节比作一个牧师，对吧？是的。我想这大概反映了他的宗教虔诚。是的，一定是的。然后，如果你看看接下来一个世纪的海外，那个时代的伟大君主查理五世，西班牙的腓力二世，都是以标志性的蓄须闻名。现在，这其中有一部分可能是……
I don't want to offend our former guest, Edward Habsburg, but this might be the Habsburg jaw issue that they want to conceal their enormous jaws but wouldn't a beard merely accentuate it i'm not sure that it would i think if you're self-conscious about jimmy hill i mean jimmy hill wore a beard didn't he to cover up his enormous chin but it just drew attention to it i think no because i i'm not sure that's right i think in the 80s jimmy hill had a clean clean chin and it was still very obvious let's not not get into that. This is for the rest is football to discuss. The rest is chins. So anyway, as we enter the 16th century, we approach one of the golden ages of the beard.
我不想冒犯我们以前的嘉宾爱德华·哈布斯堡（Edward Habsburg），但这可能是哈布斯堡家族的厚下巴问题，他们想遮住自己硕大的下巴。但难道胡须不会反而凸显它吗？我不敢说它会。我想，如果你对吉米·希尔（Jimmy Hill）式的下巴感到不自在——我的意思是，吉米·希尔留过胡子，对吧？为了遮住他巨大的下巴，但这反而把注意力吸引过去了，我认为。不，因为我——我不确定这是不是对的。我认为在80年代，吉米·希尔的下巴是刮得精光的，而且依然非常明显。我们别扯这个了。这是给《The Rest Is Football》讨论的。那是“下巴播客”。总之，当我们进入16世纪时，我们迎来了胡须的黄金时代之一。
And the historian Christopher Oldstone Moore, who specializes in the history of beards, he says there are four great beard moments in history, Tom. So the second century AD, that's Hadrian, I'm guessing. So that's Hadrian. The high middle ages, Edward III, I guess, roughly. Yeah. The Renaissance and the reign of Queen Victoria. He doesn't include the Reformation.
历史学家克里斯托弗·奥尔德斯通-穆尔（Christopher Oldstone Moore）专门研究胡须历史，他说历史上曾出现过四个伟大的蓄须时期，汤姆。公元2世纪，我猜那是哈德良时期。所以那是哈德良。中世纪盛期，我猜大约是爱德华三世时期。是的。文艺复兴时期和维多利亚女王统治时期。他没有把宗教改革算在内。
Well, we'll get onto the Reformation. The Reformation. I mean, I know you can kind of, you're often bundled two up. I think the Reformation is massive for beards. Well, I think the Reformation complicates things, as we will see. So there's another historian. You see, I've really done some digging here. There's a historian called William Fisher, who has written an article called The Renaissance Beard. And he has studied hundreds of portraits across the Tudor and Stuart period.
好吧，我们会谈到宗教改革的。宗教改革。我的意思是，我知道你某种程度上可以……你经常把这两者捆绑在一起。我认为宗教改革对胡须来说意义重大。嗯，我认为宗教改革把事情搞复杂了，正如我们将会看到的。所以还有另一位历史学家。你看，我在这里真的做了一番挖掘。有一位名叫威廉·费舍尔（William Fisher）的历史学家，他写过一篇名为《文艺复兴时期的胡须》（The Renaissance Beard）的文章。他研究了都铎和斯图亚特时期的数百幅肖像画。
And he says in those portraits, men with beards outnumber those without by 10 to 1. Is that across both Catholic and Protestant Europe? He's writing about England. But when I think about other portraits, I think England is more clean-shaven, actually, than elsewhere. I disagree. I think beards come in with the Reformation. They're massive.
他说，在这些肖像画中，留胡须的人数是没有胡须的人数的十倍。这是跨越天主教和新教欧洲的吗？他写的是英格兰。但当我想到其他肖像画时，我认为英格兰实际上比其他地方刮得更干净。我不同意。我认为胡须是随着宗教改革兴起的。它们规模巨大。
No, I think that's wrong. So you think of all those clean-shaven figures, Woolsey or Thomas More or whatever. And then with the Reformation, you suddenly get a load of beards. And I know this because I remember when I was writing about Dominion, reading about Edward VI, and he's a very sober and serious little boy, except that when the Protestant ambassadors from Germany arrive, they have enormous beards, and he gets fits of giggles about it, and then expresses his disapproval of very long beards and he gets fits of giggles about it and then expresses his disapproval of very long beards but obviously within a few years yeah beards are mainstreaming in protestant england i'm not sure this is right if you think 90 of people have beards and 10 don't if you look at some of the big
不，我认为这是错的。所以你想到所有那些刮得精光的人物，沃尔西（Wolsey）或托马斯·莫尔（Thomas More）之类的人。然后随着宗教改革，你突然看到了一大堆胡须。我知道这一点，因为我记得当我写《统治》（Dominion）一书时，读到关于爱德华六世的内容，他是一个非常严肃认真的小男孩，除了当来自德国的新教使节到达时，他们留着巨大的胡子，这让他咯咯笑个不停，然后他表达了对超长胡子的不满——这让他咯咯笑个不停，然后表达了对超长胡子的不满——但显然在几年之内，是的，胡须在新教英格兰成了主流。我不确定这是否正确。如果你认为90%的人留胡须，10%的人不留，如果你看看这个时代跨越宗教派别的几个大人物——
figures of this age across religious affiliations so thomas moore thomas cromwell thomas crammer and then go into the 17th century. The single most best known person in the 17th century, Oliver Cromwell. These are people of different religious affiliations. They're all clean shaven, which puts them in their minority. And I think in each case, their clean shavenness is about saying, I'm a sober, serious, hardworking, pious person. I agree.
比如托马斯·莫尔、托马斯·克伦威尔、托马斯·克兰麦，再进入17世纪，17世纪最知名的人物——奥利弗·克伦威尔。这些人有着不同的宗教信仰，他们都刮得精光，这使他们成了少数派。而且我认为在每一种情况下，他们刮得精光都是在表达：我是个严肃、认真、勤奋、虔诚的人。我同意。
I think, I mean, I think Puritanism takes a different course, but in the rush of the Edwardian Reformation, after Henry VIII is dead, and they can go full-in Protestant. These are the people who would give the name Protestant to Protestantism, these German ambassadors, these princes. They come to Londonon they have these very very long beards and edward vi responds with ribaldry right but then within a few years it's absolutely the fashion so cranmer grows a beard he does grow a beard and they all start growing beards in edward vi right but i think in the long run clean shavenness becomes identified with radical protestantism in the long run across the course of the 16th century but it's radical protest Protestantism because everybody's by that point is Protestant.
我认为，我的意思是，我认为清教徒主义走了一条不同的道路，但在爱德华时代的宗教改革浪潮中，在亨利八世死后，他们可以彻底倒向新教。正是这些德国使节、这些王子，赋予了新教以“新教”（Protestantism）这个名字。他们来到伦敦，留着非常非常长的胡子，爱德华六世以戏谑来回应——但随后几年里，这绝对成了时尚。所以克兰麦留了胡子，他确实留了胡子，他们在爱德华六世统治时期都开始留胡子。没错。但我认为从长远来看，光洁的面孔最终与激进新教联系在了一起。从整个16世纪的进程来看，但这是激进的新教，因为到那个时候每个人都是新教徒了。
So it's a way of, I mean, everyone has such long beards that actually shaving it off then becomes another marker of the Puritan. It does indeed. Well, do you know what Puritans thought about beards? Puritans said basically a beard is like walking around with excrements on your face. They believed, they were very much into Hildegard of Bingen's heat theory. So they said, basically, your body heat is pushing hair out of your face like soot from a chimney. And it's like you're walking around with a sooty face.
所以这成了一种方式——我的意思是，每个人都留着那么长的胡子，以至于把胡子刮掉反而成了清教徒的另一个标志。确实如此。那么，你知道清教徒对胡须有什么看法吗？清教徒基本上认为，留胡子就像顶着排泄物在街上走来走去。他们相信——他们非常推崇宾根的希尔德加德的热量理论。所以他们说，基本上，你的体温就像烟囱里的烟灰一样，把毛发从你的脸上推出来。这就好比你顶着一张满是烟灰的脸到处走。
And effectively, it's a waste product. And you are walking around because of your frivolity and your dandyism. You've smeared excrement all over your face and you're walking around with it. That's what a Puritan thinks. But I think that you have a clean-shaven ascetic look in the early part of the 16th century. Then it's full-on beards in the mid-16th century because this is the expression of Protestantism. You're doubling down on this. But then you have, towards the end of the Elizabethan period, going into the Stuart
实际上，这就是一种废弃物。而你之所以四处走红，是因为你的轻浮和花花公子的作风。你把排泄物涂满整张脸，然后顶着它到处闲逛。这就是清教徒的想法。但我认为，你在16世纪早期拥有一种刮得精光的苦行僧造型。然后到了16世纪中期，则是全方位的胡须大爆发，因为这是新教的表达。你在加倍坚持这一点。但随后，在伊丽莎白时代末期、进入斯图亚特王朝时期，胡须开始减少，因为出现了担心脸上沾满排泄物等等的清教徒。不过如果你想想德雷克（Drake）或莎士比亚式的胡子，那是那种逐渐变窄的款式。然后你有了范戴克式（Van Dyck）的胡子，对吧？但这些东西是共存的。这些东西是共存的。所以在伊丽莎白时代，不同的胡子有不同的内涵。如果你是一个士兵——
period, it's a diminishment of beards because you have the Puritans who are worried about excrement on their face and all that. But if you think about the Drake Shakespeare beard, that's kind of narrowing down. And then you have the Van Dyck beard, don't you? But these things coexist. These things coexist. So by the Elizabethan era, different beards have different connotations. So if you're a soldier- Semiotics of beards so a soldier will have a spade beard which I think is a ridiculous beard to have what does that mean what's a spade beard it's kind of
胡须的符号学。所以一个士兵会留一把铲形胡须（spade beard），我觉得这是一种荒谬的胡须。这是什么意思？什么是铲形胡须？它有点像方形的，底端是切平的。哦，是的，是的，就像路德留的那种，我猜。路德留过那个吗？对，当他还是个骑士时，他把自己伪装成骑士，对吧？他留了铲形胡子，还被人画了下来。所以，对于朝臣来说，范戴克式的胡子绝对是朝臣的胡子。这说得通，因为当然了，要维持一把范戴克式的胡子，是的，这很困难。是的，这很困难，而且很昂贵。然后还有——我最喜欢的胡子，也就是你记下来的那个“燕尾双叉”胡子，那属于某个特定人物。是的，我觉得顶着那种胡子的人，有点像现在某些人戴着平顶帽、骑着独轮车之类的人。这有点像是在标榜自己是个怪咖。现在，
square and cut off oh yes yes yes like Luther had I guess did Luther have that yeah when he was you remember when he's a knight he's disguising himself as a knight right and he grows spade beard he gets painted yeah so a courtier a van dyke beard would very much be the beard of a courtier and if that makes sense because of course to maintain a van dyke beard yeah it's difficult yeah it's difficult it's expensive and then there was um my favorite beard which is the swallowtail double pronged you've put down that belongs to a character yeah i think a character by having that beard it's a bit like being somebody now and wearing a flat cap, riding a unicycle or something. It's sort of identifying yourself as eccentric. Now,
你提到了莎士比亚。莎士比亚对胡须的描写简直绝了。因此，大多数学者都说，当你阅读莎士比亚的戏剧时，非常明显的一点是，几乎所有男性角色都留着胡子里所当然的。在《无事生非》（Much Ado About Nothing）中有一段非常著名的对话。贝特丽丝（Beatrice）在谈论——她只是在对丈夫这件事表现得有些挑剔，说她永远不会结婚。她正在和莱昂纳多（Leonato）说话，她说：“我无法忍受一个脸上有胡子的丈夫。我宁愿躺在羊毛织物里。”莱昂纳多开玩笑说：“你可以嫁给一个没有胡子的丈夫。”贝特丽丝说：“那我该拿他怎么办？把他打扮成我的女装，让他当我的贴身女侍吗？一个有胡子的男人——
you mentioned Shakespeare. Shakespeare is brilliant on beards. So most scholars say, when you read Shakespeare's plays, it's very obvious that it is taken for granted that almost every single male character will have a beard. There's a very famous exchange in Much Ado About Nothing. Beatrice is talking about, she's just sort of being difficult about husbands and how it's saying she'll never marry. And she's talking to Leonardo and she says, I could not endure a husband with a beard on his face.
贝特丽丝，那我该拿他怎么办？把他打扮成我的女装，让他当我的贴身女侍吗？一个有胡子的男人，比一个年轻人更成熟；而一个没有胡子的男人，连一个真正的男人都算不上。比年轻人更成熟的男人不适合我，连男人都算不上的我也绝不嫁给他。”你知道，当时的假设是，要成为一个男人就必须留胡子。但这里的笑话是，扮演她的将是一个没有胡子的男孩。当然。是的，完全如此。所以，没有胡子的男孩，当然，在莎士比亚和詹姆斯一世时期的戏剧中，这个短语反复出现。你知道，作为一个无须少年，就是被嘲弄的对象。然后，“直面某人”（to beard somebody）——你知道你是如何在某人的地盘上拔他们的胡须，也就是揪或拔他们的胡子。所以哈姆雷特，我们知道哈姆雷特留着胡子，因为他有一次明确地说：“我是个懦夫吗？谁叫我恶棍？打碎我的头骨，揪下我的胡子，把它吹到我的脸上。”这不仅仅是一个修辞手法。一个真正可怕的例子，也就是有人被揪了胡子，那就是格罗斯特（Gloucester），对吧？是的，当然。在《李尔王》（King Lear）中，当里根（Regan）揪住他的胡子时，他大喊：“凭着仁慈的神明，揪我的胡子，这实在是无耻之尤！”没错。
I'd rather lie in the woolen. And Leonardo says as a joke, you may lie on a husband that hath no beard. Beatrice, what should I do with him? Dress him in my apparel and make him my waiting gentlewoman? He that hath a beard beatrice what should i do with him dress him in my apparel and make him my waiting gentle woman he that hath a beard is more than a youth and he that hath no beard is less than a man and he that is more than a youth is not for me and he that is less than a man i am not for him you know the assumption is to be a man means to have a beard but the joke is that she will be
但当然，我的w意思是，这还不是最糟糕的会被揪下来的东西，因为他的眼睛稍后将被挖出来。莎士比亚还为我们描写了往往被忽视的蓄须女性。因此，在《麦克白》（Macbeth）中的女巫，班柯（Banquo）对她们说：“你们看起来像女人，然而你们的胡须却让我无法把你们当成女性。”换句话说，她们长着胡子这一事实证明了世界已经颠倒，发生了某种诡异而超自然的事情。麦克白显然没有读过老普林尼（Pliny）的书，后者对长胡子的女性着迷不已。他有一整章都在写她们。
being played by a beardless boy. Of course. Yes, exactly. So the beardless boy, of course, in Shakespeare and Jacobean drama generally, that phrase recurs. You know, to be a beardless boy is to be the object of mockery. And then to beard somebody, you know how you're bearding somebody in their den, is to pull or pluck their beard. So Hamlet, we know Hamlet had a beard because he explicitly says at one point, am I a coward?
真的吗？就像会出现在P.T.巴纳姆马戏团里的那种络腮胡女性？不。嗯，算是吧。我的意思是，有这样一个女人，一个来自阿尔戈斯的女人，她和丈夫躺在床上，丈夫睡着了，一切都很好。然后他们醒来，她竟然长出了一项胡子和一个阴茎。哇，那可真够震撼的。你知道，他很惊讶。难怪这在一夜之间发生了。没错，确信他不是跟一个男人同床共枕吗？不，他们已经结婚多年了。这不像我们听过的那个故事——呃，在……某人的一个手下，还是谁，不小心娶了——哦，是的，那个洗衣妇，她在死后被非常匆忙地埋葬了，不是那样吗？不，这些都是奇迹般的转变。
Who calls me villain? Breaks my pate across, plucks off my beard and blows it in my face. And that's more than just a figure of speech. The really awful example of that, of someone having his beard pulled is Gloucester, isn't it? Yes, of course. In King Lear, when Regan pulls on his beard and he cries out by the kind gods, tis most ignobly done to pluck me by the beard. That's right.
女性突然出乎意料地冒出胡子，这似乎成了某种普遍现象。普林尼对此非常着迷。因此，回到17世纪，显然17世纪结束时，胡须正处于大衰退之中。而且这似乎成了一种普遍现象。普林尼对此非常着迷。所以，回到17世纪，显然17世纪结束时，胡须正处于明显的衰退之中。因此，深入研究一下，历史学家对此非常感兴趣，因为实际上关于这一点的第一手资料非常少。皮普斯（Pepys）在他的日记里并没有写：“我发现胡子正在过时。我今天星期六去理发师那儿把胡子刮了。”显然，我们所使用的证据来自于肖像画之类的内容。毫无疑问，这是科学革命和启蒙运动到来的时代。再引用埃莉诺·赖克罗夫特的话，她说：
But of course, I mean, that's not the worst thing that's going to be plucked because his eyes are going to be plucked out. And Shakespeare does also give us bearded women who are often overlooked. So the witches in Macbeth, Banquo says to them, you should be women and yet your beards forbid me to interpret that you are so. In other words, the fact that they have beards proves that the world has turned upside down, something weird and supernatural. Macbeth has obviously not been reading Pliny, who was obsessed by women with beards. He had a whole
“到了18世纪，男人们几乎完全是刮得精光的。在这里，正是面部没有毛发定义了理想的男人。启蒙时代绅士的脸是光滑的，面容年轻，神色清爽，暗示着他的心灵同样是开放的。”还有人做过这方面的研究，另一本由历史学家阿兰·维西（Alan Withey）撰写的极佳的书，名为《关于胡子》（Concerning Beards）。他深入研究了这一点，并指出：18世纪，即乔治王时代，是一个充满都市气息和文明的时代。英国人是礼貌且从事商业的人，有着自觉的精致感。
chapter on them. Really? As in bearded women who would appear in P.T. Barnum's Circus? No. Well, kind of. I mean, so there's one, one this woman from argos who is in bed with her husband and he goes to sleep and it's all great then they wake up and she's she's grown a beard and a penis wow that's a shock you know he's surprised it's fair that's happened overnight yeah sure he hasn't just been to bed with a man no they've been married for years right it's not like that story that we had um the bloke in uh one of wasn't it one of custer's men or something who had accidentally married oh yes yes the washerwoman he tried to bury the washerwoman very quickly after she died isn't that it no these these are miraculous transformations right
人工修饰非常流行。它非常时髦。因此有了假发，即佩戴人造头发。这就像古埃及一样。没错。但面部毛发与之恰恰相反。它被视为粗犷、泥土气和原始的。那是劳工的外表。
women suddenly sprouting beards unexpectedly and it seems to be quite a thing i mean plenty's very into it so to return to the 17th century clearly the 17th century ends with beards in. And it seems to be quite a thing. I mean, Pliny's very into it. So to return to the 17th century, clearly the 17th century ends with beards very much in decline. So looking into it, historians are really interested in this because actually there's very little source material on it. Pepys doesn't write in his diary, I see beards are on the way out. I did this Saturday, shave off my beard to the barbers. Obviously the evidence we're using, portraits and things. And obviously, this is the age of the scientific revolution and the coming of the Enlightenment. To quote Eleanor Rycroft again, she says,
它不礼貌，它不文雅，它不是大都会风格的。阿兰·维西在理发店方面写得实在太精彩了。他说，你知道，18世纪的新理发店是这种新型公共空间的一部分。你会去那里刮胡子，可能一周去两次，你会——你知道的，这就像咖啡馆一样。那里会有报纸，你会交流八卦。当然，不同理发店的定位也不同——比如圣詹姆斯、皮卡迪利或巴斯的理发店，与伍尔弗汉普顿等地的后街理发店有很大差异。我完全理解这一点。但你还记得我们做过的那期关于西装的节目吗？是的，这是那种
By the 18th century, men were almost entirely clean-shaven. Here it was the lack of facial hair that defined the ideal man. The face of the enlightened gentleman was smooth, his face youthful, and his countenance clear, suggesting a mind that was also open. And there's somebody who's done some work, another tremendous book called Concerning Beards by the historian Alan Withey. And he sort of delves into this. And he says, the 18th century, the Georgian period is an age of urbanity, civility. Englanders are polite and commercial people, self-consciously sophisticated.
低调消费的时期。是的，我在想，仅仅是刮掉胡子——这其实也很符合一个庄重的时代。是的，然后你就没法在面部毛发上做文章了，你没法留各种各样的胡须，你没法像雷古（Ragu）阶层的花花公子那样。这里面确实有一种庄重的东西，绝对庄重。
Artifice is very popular. It's very in. Hence the wig, wearing artificial hair. So like ancient Egypt. Right. But facial hair is the opposite of that. It is seen as rough and earthy and primitive. It's the look of the laborer yeah
他还指出，这是一个剃须革命的时代，汤姆。是吗？一场剃须革命。哦，当然，谢菲尔德钢。谢菲尔德钢。因此，现在人们第一次可以在私密环境中自己刮胡子了。这在以前是没有真正发生过的。所以在
it's not polite it's not polite it's not metropolitan and he's brilliant actually alan withy on barber shops and he says you know the new barber shops of the 18th century they're part of this new kind of public space so you would go to be shaved and you would go maybe twice a week and you would you know know, it's like a coffee house. There would be newspapers and you would exchange gossip and obviously the recommendations of barbershops, you know, the barbershops in St. James's or in Piccadilly or in Bath are very different from the ones in the back streets of Wolverhampton or whatever. I entirely get that. But you remember the episode we did on the suit yeah that this is the period where it's
18世纪，谢菲尔德制造了钢制剃须刀，它们配有木质或象牙手柄。从谢菲尔德出发，它们被出口到欧洲和美洲殖民地。它们与由牛脂制成的新型肥皂、由獾毛或野猪毛制成的剃须刷相辅相成。所以，实际上我几分钟前开玩笑说圣詹姆斯或皮卡迪利的理发店——如果你现在去那里，会看到这些历史悠久的男士理发店。特朗普（Trumpers）。是的，完全如此。特朗普或者诸如此类的店。哈里斯（Harris），这些地方。
unostentatious expenditure yes and i wonder whether simply removing the beard kind of it suits a sober age as well yes then you can't do things with your facial hair yeah you can't have varieties of mustache you can't be like the dandyism of the ragu classes yeah there is something sober about it sober absolutely there is. He also points out that this is an age of a shaving revolution, Tom. Is it? A shaving revolution. Oh, well, of course, Sheffield Steel. Sheffield Steel. So now for the first time you have men shaving themselves in private. Now this had not really happened before. So
它们实际上在出售18世纪的剃须设备，只是略作了现代化升级。獾毛刷，所有诸如此类的事情。你在西部片里总是能看到这种场景，对吧？是的。所以这是一个绝对的俗套。你确实会看到。你知道，那个在西部待过的人，
in the 18th century, there are steel razors made in sheffield they will have wooden or ivory handles and from sheffield they are exported to europe and to the american colonists and they go hand in hand with new soaps made of tallow shaving brushes made from badger hair or boar hair so actually i made a quip a couple of minutes ago about barber shops in st james's or piccadilly if you you go there now, there are these kind of long-established men's shaving shops. Trumpers. Yeah, exactly. Trumpers or whatever they're called. Harris, these kind of places.
或者他刚从监狱里出来什么的，然后他走出来，涂上肥皂泡沫。没错。把肥皂泡沫涂在脸上，然后刮掉，他就焕然一新了。这很有趣。18世纪出现了第一批剃须指南。其中最著名的一本是由一个法国人写的，
They are effectively selling 18th century shaving equipment, slightly updated. The badger hair brush, all of that kind of thing. Which you always get in Westerns, don't you? Yeah. So it's an absolute trope. You do, actually. You know, the guy who's been out in the West
让-雅克·佩雷（Jean-Jacques Perrett），书名叫《剃须艺术》（Pogonotomy, or the Art of Shaving Oneself）。我看过这本书，在网上找到过PDF。所以如果你现在看一个剃须网站，重点全在于如何刮得最干净、如何实现完美的剃须。而18世纪的重点则不在于此，它基本上是如何不把自己弄死。也就是说，如何不割伤自己。而原因，当然，正如我们所说，我们马上就会谈到这一点。所以，梭罗（Thoreau），这位美国超验主义作家，他的兄弟约翰在1841年因破伤风去世，不久前他刚刚刮脸时割伤了自己。
or he's been in jail or something, then he comes out and gets the lather. That's right. The soap lathered onto his face and scrapes it off and he's as good as new. It's interesting. There are the first shaving manuals in the 18th century. So the most famous one is one by a Frenchman,
为什么？因为他刮脸时一直张着嘴。我的意思是，你怎么会得破伤风？我不知道。以某种奇特的方式感染了美国式的感染。我不明白。总之，他写了《瓦尔登湖》（On Walden Pond）或者别的什么书。
Jean-Jacques Perrette, and it's called Pogonotomy, or the Art of Shaving Oneself. But I had a look at it. I found a PDF online. So if you read a shaving website now, the emphasis is all about how to get the closest possible shave, the perfect shave. The emphasis in the 18th century is not, it's basically how not to kill yourself. So how to not cut yourself. And the reason, of course, is that we said that we would get into this. So Thoreau, the American transcendentalist writer, his brother, John, died in 1841 from lockjaw, not long after cutting himself.
我从来没读过。他一直在思考超验主义。是的，那是超验主义。这就像是在思考自然。美国人非常喜欢这种调调。总之，他这样做是因为他的兄弟死于剃须。卡那封勋爵（Lord Carnarvon）则更悲惨。是的，他在刮胡子时划破了一个蚊子包。
Why? Because he was holding his mouth open. I mean, why would you get lockjaw? I don't know. Infected. Infected in some peculiar American way. I don't understand. Anyway, he wrote On Walden Pond or whatever it's called.
是的，被蚊子咬了，刮胡子时刮破了，引发了败血症。他本可能从败血症中挺过来，结果又得了肺炎，两者的结合要了他的命。据说那个蚊子包的位置，跟图坦卡蒙（Tutankhamun）脸上的一个蚊子包在同一个地方。好吧，这其中肯定有什么联系，对吧？这是《每日邮报》宣传的。哦，这无疑是真的。皇家第一雇主。
I've never read it. He's thinking about transcendental. Yeah, it's transcendental. It's like thinking about nature. The Americans love this kind of business. Anyway, he did this because his brother had killed himself shaving. Lord Carnarvon, much more tragic. Yes, he nicked the mosquito bite.
是的。就在18世纪的剃须话题以及历史上第一次你可以自己刮胡子的兴奋感上，这让我想起了博斯韦尔（Boswell）的《约翰逊传》（Life of Johnson）中最喜欢的段落之一。多亏了你，直到这一刻我才完全体会到它的妙处。在这段里，约翰逊谈到没有哪个男人是以相同的方式刮胡子的。
Yes, bitten by a mosquito, nicks it's shaving, gets sepsis, and he might just pull through from the sepsis when he gets pneumonia and the combination of the two kills him. And it is said that the mosquito bite was in exactly the same spot as a mosquito bite on the face of Tutankhamen. Well, there's a definite link there, isn't there? This was promoted by the Daily Mail. Oh, it's undoubtedly true. First royal employer.
每个男人都有自己的技巧，自己的方法。他可能会从某个特定的角度开始，从某个特定的地方下刀。我以前总是这么想。每当我刮胡子的时候，我总是会想起这句话。但如果你是第一代真正自己动手刮胡子的人，这番话就有了全新共鸣。没有既定的模式，对吧？没有规则。但是，汤姆，当你刮胡子的时候，你会对自己说：威廉·达尔林普尔（William Dalrymple）是怎么刮胡子的？
Yeah. Just on the topic of 18th century shaving and the excitement of, for the first time in history, you can shave yourself. I'm reminded of one of my favourite passages in Boswell's Life of Johnson, which I had not fully appreciated until this moment, thanks to you, where Johnson is talking about how there is no man who shaves himself in the same way. That every man has his own technique, his own method. He might start at a certain angle, start at a certain place. And I'd always thought of that. Whenever I shave, I always remember that. But it has a whole new resonance if you are the first generation of people who are actually doing that. There's no pattern, right? There's no rule. But Tom, when you're shaving, do you think to yourself, how does William Dalrymple shave?
阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔（Alistair Campbell）是怎么刮胡子的？金汉格（Goldhanger）播客的其他主持人是怎么刮胡子的？这就是你脑子里想的事情吗？不，我总是想：约翰逊博士会怎么刮胡子？我想他会是一片混乱。以一种随心所欲的方式……他大概就是那样刮胡子的。他肯定是个胡子没刮干净的人。毫无疑问。是的，他的假发会是歪的，脸上会贴满用来遮挡刮伤的小膏药。所以，在我们休息前，再讲一件18世纪的事。但这超出了西方的范围，我们已经走出了西欧。因此，这对所有说我们是欧洲中心主义的人是一个沉重的回击——我们要走到西欧以外大约20英里远的地方。是的，我们对胡子做了一点调整。那些说我们……所以我们在
How does Alistair Campbell shave? How do the other Goldhanger podcast presenters shave? Is that what's going through your mind? No, I always think, how would Dr. Johnson shave? Chaotically, I think. In a haphazard... That's how he'd shave. He would be a poorly shaved man. No question. Yes, his wig would be askew and he'd have loads of little plasters over his face where he'd nicked himself. So before we get to the break, one more 18th century thing. But it's outside West, we've gone outside Western Europe. So this is a stunning rebuke to everybody who says who says we're eurocentric we're going about 20 miles outside western europe yeah we tweak the beard those who say that so we're in
彼得大帝统治下的俄罗斯。彼得大帝生于1672年，身处一个胡子不仅是常态、而且我敢说是具有神圣性的社会。神圣性。因为它们是东正教的象征。所以，你知道，那些胡须传承自正统教会的血统。罗伯特·K·马西（Robert K. Massey）在他的彼得大帝传记中写道，胡子是上帝赐予的装饰，由先知、使徒和耶稣本人所佩戴。伊凡雷帝（Ivan the Terrible）就留着一把极了不起的大胡子。他说：剃掉胡子是一种罪过，所有的殉道者的鲜血都无法洗净。这是对上帝创造的男人形象的亵渎。许多大主教都对此表示支持，他们会说，你知道的，一个没有胡子的人是无法得到祝福的。一个没有胡子的人是在向上帝吐口水。我在你的笔记里读到，这个白痴——17世纪末的大主教阿德里安（Patriarch Adrian）曾说过：
russia under peter the great so peter the great born in 1672 in a society where beards are they're not just the norm they're dare i say sacral, sacral. Well, because they're Orthodox. Yes. And so, you know, those beards come in a line of descent from the original church. Yes. Robert K. Massey, in his biography of Peter the Great, says the beard was the ornament given by God, worn by the prophets, the apostles, and Jesus himself. Ivan the Terrible had a tremendous beard. He said, to shave the beard is a sin that the blood of all the martyrs cannot cleanse. It is to deface the image of a man created by God. Lots of patriarchs kind of back that up and they would say, you know, a man without a beard can't be blessed. A man without a beard is spitting in the face of God. I'm reading in your notes, this idiot, Patriarch Adrian in the late 17th century,
上帝创造男人时并非没有胡子，只有猫和狗才没有。他显然从来没见过长须牧羊犬（bearded collie）。没有。这是我们养的第一只狗。真的吗？嗯，就像雪纳瑞。雪纳瑞有胡子。对，但它不叫“长须雪纳瑞”。对，不叫。长须牧羊犬显然是有胡子的。我可以作证，本（Ben）有一把巨大的胡子。
who said, God did not create men beardless, only cats and dogs. He's obviously never met a bearded collie. No. It's the first dog we had. Really? Well, like a schnauzer. A schnauzer has a beard. Yeah, but it's not called a bearded schnauzer. No, it's not. A bearded collie is obviously bearded. And I can vouch that Ben had a massive beard.
大主教阿德里安。大主教，我的意思是，他简直是个白痴。他对这事一无所知。不。他对这事一无所知。我不知道他在胡说八道些什么。总之，在彼得大帝出生的时候，光洁的面孔已经在俄罗斯悄然蔓延了。因为在莫斯科有一个叫做“德国人区”（German suburb）的地方。
Patriarch Adrian. Patriarch, I mean, he's absolutely idiotic. He knew nothing of it. No. He knew nothing of it. I don't know what he's talking about. Anyway, clean shaving has seeped into Russia by the time of Peter the Great's birth. Because there's this place inco called the German suburb.
东正教的大主教和神父们会说，德国人区里正发生着可怕的场景：人们在说德语，在吃沙拉，在搞七捻三，而且还在刮胡子。这简直令人发指。所有思想端正的俄罗斯人都认为这是绝对可耻的行为。总之，正如你所知，汤姆，彼得大帝踏上了他的伟大欧洲之旅，对吧？阿姆斯特丹、约翰·伊夫林的宅邸、德普特（Deptford），应有尽有。然后他
And patriarchs and Orthodox priests would say terrible scenes in the German suburb. People are talking in German, they're eating salads, they're taking stuff, and they're shaving their faces. And this is abhorrent. And all right-thinking Russians say this is absolutely disgraceful behaviour. Anyway, as you will know, Tom, Peter the Great goes off on his great European tour, doesn't he? Amsterdam, John Evelyn's house, Deptford, you name it. And he
在1698年回国了。他做的第一件事——我的意思是，在回到莫斯科的几小时内——就把他的波雅尔（boyars，即贵族）召集起来，亲自为他们刮胡子。所以他抓住他们的脸，粗暴地一个接一个地给他们刮胡子。他们对此都感到相当震惊。但这就是他打算推行的方式。接着，他开始邀请客人共进晚餐，并让他的宫廷小丑强行给客人们刮胡子。最后他说：听着，我不是在开玩笑。如果你想留胡子，你就得交税。人们必须交税，人们必须交这笔税，这是一个根据你财富多少而定的累进税。一旦你交了税，你就会得到一枚勋章，上面印着胡子的图案，并刻有“已交税”字样。如果你
comes back in 1698. And one of the very first things he does, I mean, within hours of returning to Moscow, he calls in his boyars, his kind of nobles, and he physically shaves them himself. So he grabs their faces and roughly shaves them one by one. And they're all quite shocked by this. But this is how he means to go on. Then he starts to have visitors for dinner and he gets his jester to forcibly shave them. And then eventually he says, listen, I'm not messing around here. If you want to have a beard, you have to pay a tax. And people would have to pay a tax and people would have to pay this tax it was a graduated tax based on how much money you had once you paid it you were given a medallion with a picture of a beard on it and the words tax paid and if you were walking
带着胡子在大街上闲逛却没有这枚勋章，你就会拥有一把违法的胡子。这或许是蕾切尔·里夫斯（Rachel Reeves）可以思考一下、用来填补财政黑洞的方法。请问，这是因为他热衷于将他的人民欧洲化、西方化吗？他想打破保守的东正教当局的权力。当然，他还坚持要求人们穿欧洲服饰、西方服饰。我的意思是，他全心全意致力于西方化。许多俄罗斯人感到非常震惊。因此，尽管彼得大帝是一个独裁者、开明专制君主、绝对君主，所以没有人能跟他顶嘴，但许多人认为：如果我没胡子就死了，我会惹上大麻烦的。
around with a beard without this medallion you'll have an illegal beard something for rachel reeves to ponder perhaps fill in Fill in that fiscal black hole. Can I just ask, is this because he is keen to Europeanize, to westernize his people? He wants to break the power of the conservative orthodox authorities. He also insists, of course, that people dress in a European way, in a Western way. I mean, he's all about westernization. And a lot of Russians are very shocked. So although Peter the Great is an autocrat, an enlightened despot, an absolute monarch, so there's no arguing with him, a lot of people think, if I die beardless, I'm going to be in terrible trouble.
罗伯特·K·马西的书里有一句精彩的引文。一个英国旅行者正在跟一个当地人交谈，那人大概是个造船匠之类的，没有胡子。英国人说：“哦，你知道的，你没有胡子。你显然加入了彼得大帝的阵营。”那人回答：“其实我有一把胡子。”他伸手进口袋，掏出一个小袋子或什么东西，说道：“我出门从不不带它，因为我可能会死，我需要它。我需要把它带在身上，好向他们证明我其实还留着胡子。”
And there's a wonderful quote in the Robert K. Massey book. An English traveler was talking to this guy who was like a shipwright or something who had no beard. He said, oh, you know, you've got no beard. You've obviously signed up to Peter the Great's thing. And he said, I do have a beard, actually. He kind of reached into his pocket and he got out this pouch or something. And he said, I never go out without it because I could die and I will need it.
这会是个很有用的伪装，对吧？会的，但你也得随身带胶水吗？因为你的胡子会失去原本的粘性，汤姆。我想是的。你不能直接把它重新贴上去。是的。当我们第二部分聊到披头士乐队时，我们会谈到那种可以贴上去的假胡子。
I will need to have it on me to show them that I've still got my beard. It would be a useful disguise, wouldn't it? It would be, but would you have to take glue as well with you? Because your beard would have lost its integrity time. I suppose. You couldn't just reattach it. Yes. We'll be getting on to beards that you can attach when we talk about the Beatles in the
太棒了。那么，听着，我们在这里休息一下。等我们回来后，我们将探讨克里米亚战争。是的，比如达尔文的胡子之类的。巨大的维多利亚式大胡子。我们还将探讨披头士乐队、嬉皮士和嬉 hipster。
second half. Great. Well, listen, let's take a break here. And when we come back, we'll be looking at the Crimean war. Yeah. Kind of Darwin's beard, that kind of thing. Big Victorian beards. And we'll be looking at the Beatles and War, kind of Darwin's beard, that kind of thing, big Victorian beards, and we'll be looking at the Beatles and hippies and hipsters.
是的，有太多内容值得期待了。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱。
Yeah. So much to look forward to. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment
是啊。有太多值得期待的事情了。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐秘史》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦娱乐的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为您揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest is History. And we're looking at the history of the beard. And Dominic, we left part one looking at beards in the age of Peter the Great. And we're going to leap forwards, but remain in Russia. Or more specifically in the Crimea, where Britain and France go to war with Russia. And this is a seismic event, isn't it, in the history of the beard? It's absolutely massive. So at this point, mid-19th century, there is a within russia itself so peter the great had wanted everyone to be
我们来告诉你这背后的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的音频、获取加更节目以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史余音》（The Rest is History）。本期节目我们来探讨胡须的历史。多米尼克，在上半集节目结束时，我们讲到了彼得大帝时期的胡须。接下来我们要把时间大大向前推进，但依然留在俄国。更准确地说，是英法两国与俄国开战的克里米亚。这可以说是胡须历史上具有震撼性的一大事件，对吧？绝对是一件大事。所以在19世纪中期这个时候，在俄国国内——彼得大帝曾要求所有人都
clean shaved but by the mid-19th century people are wearing beards and of course the last russian czars have beards so alexander the third and nicholas the second both have beards now this is often seen as a reflection of their slavophile tendencies in other words they are casting off the legacy of Peter the Great, and they're saying, no, no, no, we're not westernized. We are Russians. We are Slavs. We have a unique soul, and we have our tremendous beards. But actually, they are also reflecting Western fashion,
刮得光溜溜的，但到了19世纪中期，人们开始蓄起胡须，当然，最后的几位俄国沙皇也都留着胡须，亚历山大三世和尼古拉二世都留着胡须。这通常被视为他们斯拉夫主义倾向的体现，换句话说，他们正在抛弃彼得大帝的政治遗产，并表明：不，不，不，我们没有西化。我们是俄国人。我们是斯拉夫人。我们拥有独特的灵魂，我们还有着壮观的大胡子。但实际上，他们也是在呼应西方时尚，
and that Western fashion has changed because of events in Russia, ironically, because of the Crimean War. Because as you said, from 1853 to 1856, the British and the French are fighting the Russians in the Crimea. This is a horrendous conflict. It's the first modern war, really. It's got shells, it's got railways, telegraph, photographs, all of that stuff. Now, at the beginning, so Lord Raglan,
而且这种西方时尚的改变正是由于俄国国内发生的事件——具有讽刺意味的是，正是因为克里米亚战争。因为正如你所说，从1853年到1856年，英法联军在克里米亚与俄国人作战。这是一场极其可怕的冲突。它可以说是第一场真正意义上的现代战争。它有炮弹、铁路、电报、照片，所有这些东西。现在，一开始时——比如拉格兰勋爵，
we had that lovely quote from him of dubious provenance, beards are foreign and breed vermin. But whether or not British troops wanted to grow beards, they have to grow them because they are in the field for months in horrendous conditions. They have no soap. It is so cold that the water is frozen so they couldn't really shave or wash, even if they wanted to. And as a of course they're being photographed and those photographs come back home and the beards come to be seen as badges of military status of kind of manliness and prestige and so is that what inspires the great victorian beard that's what historians alan withy talks about this so darwin yeah tennyson i think you could
我们听过他那句出处存疑的名言：“胡须是外国的东西，还会滋生寄生虫。”但不管英国士兵是否愿意蓄胡子，他们都不得不留胡子，因为他们在野外恶劣的条件下度过了好几个月。他们没有肥皂。天气冷得水都结冰了，所以哪怕他们想刮胡子或洗脸也根本做不到。因此，自然而然地，他们被拍照了，这些照片传回了国内，胡须开始被视为军事地位、某种男子气概和声望的象征。那么，这是否就是启发了伟大的维多利亚时代胡须的原因呢？历史学家阿兰·威西（Alan Withy）谈过这一点，达尔文，还有——我想你可以
argue i suppose you would have to do a study of portraits from the 1850s, the previous decade, to see if beards were coming back, which I imagine they almost certainly were beforehand. But I guess this accelerates, amplifies the process. And I'm not just saying this because he's a cricketer, but WG Grace is massive in this, isn't he? Because he, to explain for people who don't know who he is, he is the first mass appeal sportsman who's, first of all, he's drawn and then he's photographed. And his beard is the icon of his prowess as a sportsman. And so beards then come to be associated with the virility of someone who's an elite sportsman.
认为——当然，你可能需要研究一下1850年代及之前十年间的肖像画，看看胡须是否正在回归，我猜在此之前它们几乎是肯定在回归的。但我想这加速并放大了这一进程。我这么说不仅仅是因为他是个板球运动员，WG·格雷斯（WG Grace）在这方面影响巨大，对吧？因为——向不认识他的人解释一下——他是第一个具有大众吸引力的运动员，他先是被画下来，然后被拍照。他的胡子成为了他作为运动员精湛球技的标志。因此，胡须随后开始与顶尖运动员的充沛精力联系在一起。
Yeah, I think that's fair. I think we think of Victorian beards as backward. But of course, if you're looking forwards from the late 1850s onwards, the beard is modern. The beard is a rejection of the previous period of clean shavenness. And a beard is seen as, what is it? I guess it's patriarchal. It's individualistic.
对，我觉得这很合理。我们通常认为维多利亚时代的胡须比较落后。但当然，如果你从1850年代末期开始向前看，胡须其实是现代的。胡须是对前一个清洁刮面时期的否定。而且胡子被视为——它是什么？我猜它是家长制的。它是个人主义的。
It's individualistic and it's cutting edge. Because the other thing about WG Grace is that he is the first real celebrity who lends his name and his image to advertisers. So he advertised Coleman mustard and the fact that he is instantly recognizable because he has this incredibly distinctive beard is obviously a crucial part of that because it's very, very easy to reproduce. I think consumerism, advertising and photography are really important in the growth of the beard so there's a good american example it's not quite a beard but it's similar there's a guy in the american civil war so we're talking about a decade later called major general ambrose burnside a union general and burnside if you google him you will see he has the most extraordinary whiskers.
它是个人主义的，而且是极其前卫的。因为WG·格雷斯的另一个特点是，他是第一个真正的名人，将自己的名字和形象借给了广告商。他曾为科尔曼芥末（Coleman's Mustard）做过广告，由于他有着极其标志性的大胡子，人们能一眼认出他，这显然是成功的一个关键部分，因为这种形象非常非常容易复制。我认为消费主义、广告和摄影对于胡须的兴起真的非常重要。这里有一个很好的美国例子，虽然算不上纯粹的胡子，但很类似：美国内战期间（也就是大约十年后），有一个叫安布罗斯·伯恩赛德（Ambrose Burnside）的少将，他是联邦军队的将军。如果你去谷歌一下伯恩赛德，你会看到他有着最不可思议的络腮胡。
So sort of sideburns that then turn into a moustache and kind of meet in the middle. It's Burnside who gave his name to those sideburns. The sideburn was named after him. And of course, that's because images of him are being spread across the United States in a way that they weren't, you know, they wouldn't have been 10 or 20 years earlier because of the development of photography and so on. So the beard has become very fashionable. It's seen as incarnating the new martial values of the 1850s, 1860s. But people are also, of course, looking for other justifications because this is also a heyday of medicine and science. You mentioned Darwin.
也就是那种鬓角向下延伸，然后连成八字胡并在中间汇合的样式。就是伯恩赛德的名字催生了英文中的“鬓角”（sideburns）一词，鬓角就是以他的名字命名的。当然，这是因为他的照片正在全美各地传播，其传播程度是十年前或二十年前由于摄影技术的发展而无法实现的。因此，胡子变得非常时髦。它被视为化身了1850年代、1860年代的新尚武价值观。但人们当然也在寻找其他的合理化解释，因为这也是医学和科学的全盛时期。你提到了达尔文。
So Darwin probably thinks, I mean, I've never read Darwin about his own beard, but I imagine he would have thought a beard was healthy. Otherwise he wouldn't have had one. Well, we talked about him at the start of the first show. He's unclear what the evolutionary purpose of beards is, but essentially, I mean, he thinks that they are advertisements of virility that appeal to women and therefore natural selection chooses men with men who can grow beards yeah and actually if you look at scientific textbooks and tracts and things from this period so alexander
所以达尔文可能认为——我的意思是，我从来没读过达尔文关于他自己胡子的言论，但我猜他会认为留胡子是健康的。否则他也不会留胡子了。我们在第一集的开头聊过他，目前尚不清楚胡须进化的目的是什么，但本质上，他认为胡须是能吸引女性的雄性气概的广告，因此自然选择会倾向于挑选那些能够长出胡须的男性。是的，实际上，如果你看看这一时期的科学教科书、小册子之类的内容——比如亚历山大·
roland the human hair popularly and physiologically considered he writes in that i do most strenuously contend that the beard is a positive good. It affords naturally what we are forced to supply artificially, i.e. warmth and protection to the throat. And then there's St. James's Magazine from 1861, so that's right in the point between the Crimean War and the American Civil War. A long beard contributes greatly to health. It preserves the teeth a long time from
罗兰（Alexander Rowland）所著的《人类毛发的通俗与生理学考察》（The Human Hair Popularly and Physiologically Considered），他在书中写道：“我极力主张，胡须是一件绝对的好事。它自然地提供了我们被迫人工补充的东西，即对喉咙的保暖和保护。”然后还有1861年的《圣詹姆斯杂志》（St. James's Magazine），这正处于克里米亚战争和美国内战之间的节点：“长长的胡须对健康大有裨益。它能长期保护牙齿免于
rotting and strengthens the gums. So this is apparently based on a 16th century physician called Valerianus. I don't believe a beard does strengthen your gums. If there are any specialists in gums, let us know. Dominic, just on that topic, I mean, this is kind of almost taking us back to ancient Greece, isn't it? A beard is medically something that a man should have. And that was an age where a very strong sense of the separation of the rival spheres of men and women. Do you think, because paralleling the growth of the Victorian beard is a kind of emphasis on the domestic role of women, the angel in the house.
腐烂，并能强健牙龈。”这显然是基于一位十六世纪名叫瓦莱里亚努斯（Valerianus）的医生的观点。我不相信留胡子能强健牙龈。如果有任何牙龈方面的专家，请让我们知道。多米尼克，顺着这个话题说，这几乎把我们带回了古希腊，对吧？从医学角度来看，留胡子是一个男人应该做的事。那也是一个对男女对立领域的分离有着强烈意识的时代。你是否认为——因为维多利亚时代胡须的兴起，伴随着对女性家庭角色的强调，也就是“屋里的天使”。
Do you think that's part of it? I do. And lots of gender historians think it is. Lots of gender historians say that at points when women's roles are changing, expanding, when women are maybe threatening men in various ways, men will feel the need to assert their masculinity in more visible and conspicuous ways. Interesting. Generally by facial hair, that that would be a good explanation. But the thing about the medical stuff is that once you've thrown your lot in with doctors and scientists, of course, when they change your mind. They can come up with any old nonsense.
你觉得这也是原因之一吗？我确实这么认为。许多性别史学家也这么认为。许多性别史学家指出，在女性角色发生变化、不断扩大、女性在各个方面可能对男性构成威胁的时期，男性会觉得有必要以更明显、更引人注目的方式来宣示他们的男子气概。有趣。通常是通过面部毛发来宣示，这倒是一个很好的解释。但关于医学说辞的那部分，一旦你把自己的命运和医生、科学家绑定在一起，当他们改变主意时，
Right, exactly. Once they've changed their minds, you're in real trouble. So by the end of the 19th century, the turn of the 20th, the consensus has changed. People think beards might not be very hygienic. Christopher Oldston Moore and his stuff think beards might not be very hygienic christopher oldston more on his stuff about beards he says the discoveries of louis pasteur are crucial in this so pasteur germ theory microbes all of that business and people who were kind of pasteurites or whatever
他们就能扯出任何荒谬的无稽之谈。
would say your beard is a breeding ground for disease a french scientist caused a sensation in 1907 i mean this is the most french experiment that's ever taken place they didn't experiment and he said the lips i quote the lips of a woman kissed by a mustachioed man were polluted with tuberculosis and diphtheria bacteria as well as food particles and a hair from a spider's leg. And what was the point of that? So basically, this woman, they got men to kiss women. Yeah.
没错，正是如此。一旦他们改变了主意，你就真的有大麻烦了。因此，到了19世纪末20世纪初，科学界的共识已经改变了。人们认为胡须可能并不那么卫生。克里斯托弗·奥尔德斯顿-摩尔（Christopher Oldston-Moore）关于胡须的研究指出，路易·巴斯德的发现在这其中至关重要，因为巴斯德的细菌理论、微生物学等等这些概念，当时那些所谓的巴斯德信徒或其他什么人
Very French. Some men with moustaches, some men without. And the moustache showed men afterwards when they tested the women's lips, covered with filth, spiders. Oh, I see. Bits of French food. They hadn't deliberately polluted this guy's moustache with spider's legs. No, he was just French. He just had it? Yeah. Okay. Oh, yes, I see. Bits of French food. They hadn't deliberately polluted this guy's moustache with spider's legs and things. No, he was just French.
会说，你的胡子是疾病的滋生地。19th世纪一位法国科学家在1907年引起了轰动——我的意思是，这简直是史上最具有法国特色的一场实验。他们做了一个实验，他说——我引述原话：“被留胡子的男子亲吻过的女人的嘴唇，会受到结核杆菌和白喉杆菌的污染，同时还夹杂着食物残渣以及蜘蛛腿上的一根毛发。”那这个实验的意义何在呢？基本上就是，这个女人——他们找来男人亲吻女人。对。
He just had it? Yeah. Okay. Oh, yes, I see. So nobody wants that. No woman wants to be kissed and be left with all this detritus. That spider's leg. No, not at all.
非常法式。有些男人留着胡须，有些没有。那些留胡子的男人在亲吻之后，当他们检测女人的嘴唇时，发现上面沾满了污垢、蜘蛛。噢，我明白了。还有法式食物的残渣。他们并不是故意用蜘蛛腿去污染这家伙的胡子。不，他只是个法国人。他本来就那样？对。好吧。噢，是的，我明白了。所以没有人想要那样。没有女人愿意在被亲吻后留下一堆这样的残渣。还有那只蜘蛛腿。不，完全不想。
But also, I think there's a cultural shift. So thinking about, obviously, we've talked about the Edwardian period a fair amount in our Roads of the Great War series and so on. Well, first of all, it's an age when socially there is a turn towards greater kind of corporate. Historians talk about this move to a kind of corporate uniformity. More people working in offices, more clerks, more white collar than before. You want a kind of uniform workforce.
但我也认为，这其中存在着一种文化转变。想想看，我们在“大战之路”（Roads of the Great War）等系列节目中已经花了不少篇幅讨论爱德华时代。首先，这是一个在社会层面上转向某种企业化特征的时代。历史学家经常谈到这种向某种企业化整齐划一的转变。越来越多的人在办公室工作，越来越多的职员，穿白领衬衫的人比以前更多了。你需要一支整齐划一的劳动力队伍。
And the idea of everybody turning up with that random long beard is anathema to the Edwardians. They want everyone sitting in rows looking the same. But at the same time, there's a great emphasis in the Edwardian period on youth and vigor and on looking dynamic. And of course, casting off the shackles of the previous generation. So actually, when you look at some of the characters we've talked about in various episodes, 1890s, 1900s, Oscar Wilde, Herbert Asquith, the young Winston Churchill, they're all clean shaven.
每个人都顶着一头参差不齐的长胡子出现，这种想法是爱德华时代的人所深恶痛绝的。他们希望每个人都坐在长椅上，看起来一模一样。但与此同时，爱德华时代非常强调青春、活力以及充满朝气的外表。当然，这也是要摆脱上一代人的枷锁。因此，事实上，当你看看我们在各个剧集中讨论过的一些人物——1890年代、1900年代的王尔德、赫伯特·阿斯奎斯、年轻的温斯顿·丘吉尔，他们全都是光洁的面庞。
Even more reactionary figures. So great pals of the rest is history like Kaiser Wilhelm II. Good moustache though. Moustache, but not bearded. And I think the fact that Franz Ferdinand of of all people, is not bearded tells its own story, Tom. It's most sensible if people take their fashion cues from the Archduke. But there's also a technical explanation, which is shaving. So shaving has changed.
甚至连那些更保守的人物也是如此。比如《历史余音》的老朋友——德皇威廉二世。不过胡子倒挺好。有八字胡，但没有大胡子。我想，弗朗茨·斐迪南大公这样的人物居然都不留胡子，本身就说明了一些问题，汤姆。如果人们效仿大公的时尚，那才是最明智的做法。但这里还有一个技术层面的解释，那就是刮胡子。刮胡子这件事变了。
So there's a guy called King Camp Gillette. And in 1895, he's sitting around in Chicago, I think it is, and he thinks there must be a better way to shave than this. And he basically dreams up the idea of the disposable razor blade. And it took him the best part of a decade to start producing it, to work out what the design would be and whatnot. He does that in 1903, I think. And by the end of the 1900s, he's producing them in London and Paris.
有一个叫金·坎普·吉列（King Camp Gillette）的人。1895年，我记得他正坐在芝加哥，心想刮胡子肯定有比这更好的方法。于是他基本上构思出了“一次性剃须刀片”的想法。他花了大半个十年才开始生产它，研究它的设计应该是什么样的等等。我想他在1903年做到了这一点。到了1900年代末，他已经在伦敦和巴黎生产这种刀片了。
But then it's turbocharged by the First World War. Because in the First World War, first of all, officers want their men to look the same, to have a kind of uniformity. You can't have people with like swallowtail beards. No, especially not in the trenches with all that mud. It's lice that is the thing. You want to basically eliminate anything where germs and lice will grow. So, for example, when the US joined the war in 1917, troops were told, you must travel with the shaving kits that you provide yourself.
但随后，第一次世界大战让剃须需求呈火箭式爆发。因为在第一次世界大战中，首先，军官们希望手下的士兵看起来千篇一律，保持某种整齐划一。你不能让士兵留着像燕尾一样的胡子。不行，尤其是在到处都是泥泞的战壕里。虱子才是真正的问题所在。你基本上要消灭任何会滋生病菌和虱子的东西。因此，例如，当美国在1917年参战时，部队被告知：你们必须自带剃须套装出行。
And Gillette made packs specially for the trenches. And was it the best a man can get? I think it almost certainly was, Tom. I can't believe Gillette aren't sponsoring this, actually. Well, they know where we are. When the war is over, these are dark days for beards, actually. Because think about the interwar years. Nobody has a beard in the interwar years nobody has a beard in the
于是吉列专门为战壕生产了套装。这是男人能得到的最好的东西吗？我想几乎可以说是的，汤姆。我简直不敢相信吉列居然没有赞助这期节目。好吧，他们知道我们在哪儿。战争结束后，对胡子来说这其实是黑暗的日子。因为想想两次世界大战之间的小间期。战间期没有人留胡子。战间期
interwar years lenin lenin lenin bandite beard and george v ironically two people george berners shaw is he still around he's got an amazing beard yeah but he's just a leftover from the previous yeah he is water rally he's left over yeah even stalin doesn't have a beard to stalin who'd been raised in the seminary he has a mustache hitler has a mustache unthinkable that either of those men would have a beard. Stanley Baldwin, no beard. Neville Chamberlain, no beard. Franklin Roosevelt, no beard. And actually- Trotsky. Trotsky, beard, but that ends up with an ice pick in his head. This is what happens. I think communists are likelier to have beards.
没有人留胡子。列宁，列宁留着匪气十足的胡子；还有乔治五世，讽刺的是，就这两个人。萧伯纳还在吗？他有一大把惊人的胡子——对，但他只是前一个时代的遗老——是的，他是个活化石，他是遗老。甚至连斯大林也没有胡子——在神学院长大并留着八字胡的斯大林，希特勒也留着八字胡，这两个人留胡子是不可想象的。斯坦利·鲍德温，没胡子。内维尔·张伯伦，没胡子。富兰克林·罗斯福，没胡子。事实上——托洛茨基。托洛茨基留着胡子，但他的结局是头上挨了一记冰镐。事情就是这样。我觉得共产主义者好像更容易留胡子。
They are. And they give beards a bad name. So here's the interesting thing, that if you look at the popular culture,'s just look at the british popular culture of the interwar years very quickly beards are identified with freakishness so is that your synonym for people with left-wing so to give one of my favorite examples in the just williams stories of which will compton which are a brilliant window into the mentality in middle england in williams village when somebody with a beard moves in next door, he's a league of nations enthusiast or a vegetarian or something. When George Orwell in the 1930s is describing the weirdos who give socialism a bad name, that quote,
确实如此。而且他们让胡子名声扫地。所以有趣的是，如果你看看大众文化——我们非常快地看一下两次大战间期的英国大众文化——胡子被视为怪异的代名词。所以这是你对左翼人士的同义词吗？为了举一个我最喜欢的例子，在里奇曼·康普顿（Richmal Crompton）的“威廉系列”（Just William Stories）中——这为了解英格兰中部普通民众的心态提供了一扇绝佳的窗口——在威廉的村子里，当一个留着胡子的人搬到隔壁时，他要么是国际联盟的狂热支持者，要么是个素食主义者之类的。当乔治·奥威尔在1930年代描述那些给社会主义抹黑的怪咖时，那句名言——
that dreary tribe of high-minded women and sandal wearers and bearded fruit juice drinkers. And then in one of my favorite books lucky jim published 1954 i think or 1953 i can't remember which dixon the hero sort of failed historian he espies his love rival who's called bertrand who is a terrible man bertrand is wearing a lemon yellow sports coat all three buttons of which were fastened which is very poor and displaying a large beard which came down further on one side than the other. And Dixon guessed straight away that this must be Bertrand, who has already been described to him as A, a pacifist,
“那一群沉闷的高尚女性、穿凉鞋的人和喝留须果汁的人。”然后在我最喜欢的一本小说《幸运的吉姆》（Lucky Jim）中——出版于1954年或1953年，我记不清具体哪一年了——主角迪克森（Dixon）是一个有点失败的历史学家，他瞥见了情敌伯特兰（Bertrand）。伯特兰是个讨厌鬼，穿着一件柠檬黄的运动西装，三个扣子全系上了，这品味实在太差，而且还留着一大把胡子，一边比另一边长。迪克森一眼就猜出这肯定就是伯特兰，因为之前别人已经向他描述过伯特兰：A，是个和平主义者；
B, somebody who likes painting, and so therefore automatically just a terrible man. We're no longer into notions of purity and royalty and all the stuff that we were looking at in ancient times and medieval times. And we're not really even into health by now. It's about fashion. But it has a political meaning, I think. Of course, because all fashions do. But for men, what you do with your facial hair, it's something that you can change very, very easily. So you can experiment. I guess that on the level of nationwide fashions, if one generation has beards, then the obvious thing to do is to shave them off in the next generation. And so hostile attitudes to beards
B，是一个喜欢画画的人，因此自然而然地就是个讨厌鬼。我们不再沉迷于纯洁、皇室以及我们在古代和中世纪所探讨的那些概念了。到了现在，甚至连健康也不再是重点。这完全关乎时尚。但我认为这具有政治意义。当然，因为所有的时尚都具有政治意义。但对于男人来说，你对脸部毛发所做的处理，是一件非常非常容易改变的事情。所以你可以进行试验。我猜，在全国性时尚的层面上，如果一代人留了胡子，那么下一代人显而易见要做的事情就是把它刮掉。所以对胡子的敌意态度——
in the fifties, isn't that when? Yeah, fifties. Must be setting things up for the sixties, which is one of the great ages of the popular beard. Well, it is and isn't, Tom, I would say, about the 60s and pears. Well, it's fashionable, isn't it? But of course, I mean, I know that Sandbrook's people would not be wearing beards. Is that the technical term? Movers and shakers like John Lennon, they are. Well, here's the interesting thing. You have the development of youth culture, let's say the mid-50s onwards and hair for example is always a huge part of that and whether you have a kind of crew cut or a kind of elvis style haircut or you have a beatles mop
在50年代，难道不是那个时候吗？对，50年代。这必定是在为60年代做铺垫，而60年代是大众胡须最盛行的黄金时代之一。嗯，可以说是，也可以说不是，汤姆，关于60年代和胡须，我想这么说。好吧，当时这很流行，对吧？但当然，我知道桑布鲁克（Sandbrook）的研究对象是不会留胡子的。这是专业术语吗？像约翰·列侬这样的弄潮儿确实留了。嗯，有趣的地方在于：青年文化从50年代中期开始蓬勃发展，比如说，发型一直是其中极其重要的一部分。无论你留的是平头、猫王风格的发型、披头士拖把头，
or hippie hair or whatever or punk all of those kinds of things and yet actually through the great majority of all these trends there was an assumption you'll always be clean shaven. You might be stubbly because you haven't bothered to shave, but you won't be bearded or really mustachioed. Now, there is a slight exception for that, which is the Beatles. But more generally, the Summer of Love and Inter68. If you look at photos, the great majority of men are not bearded.
还是嬉皮士长发、朋克头，所有这些发型层出不穷，然而在所有这些潮流的大多数时间里，人们始终有一种默认的前提：你必须干干净净地刮胡面。你可能会有胡茬，因为你懒得刮胡子，但你绝对不会留大胡子，甚至连八字胡也很少。不过有一个微小的例外，那就是披头士。但更普遍的是，在爱之夏（Summer of Love）和1968年期间，如果你看看照片，绝大多数男人其实都没有留胡子。
Oh, are they not? That's interesting. They're long haired, but they're not bearded. I was having a look because I was thinking about exactly this thing. So the Beatles started flirting with mustaches and beards at the end of 1966, then the beginning of 1967. Then they all really have them in, I think, May 67, when they publicly launch Sergeant Pepper. And to get a sense of how outlandish that is, if you just look at the World Cup final of 1966, A, you look at the England team, they've got very short hair and they're all clean shaven. They're not even stubbly. They're all clean shaven. And then you look at the crowd. There are virtually no beards. There are very
噢，真的吗？这太有趣了。他们留着长发，但没有留胡子。我当时还特意查了一下，因为我刚好在思考这个问题。披头士是在1966年底开始尝试八字胡和大胡子的，然后是1967年初。接着他们所有人都在——我想大概是1967年5月——公开推出《佩珀军士》（Sergeant Pepper）专辑时，真正留起了胡子。为了让你了解这有多么离经叛道，如果你看看1966年的世界杯决赛：首先，看看英格兰队，他们的头发非常短，而且都刮得光溜溜的。他们连胡茬都没有。全都是干干净净的光面。然后你再看看观众席。几乎看不到胡子。其实连
few moustaches, actually. They're all clean shaven. And with the Beatles, is it the Maharishi that changes it? No, they've grown them before they've gone to Rishikesh. They go to Rishikesh a year later. They haven't grown the beard by then, have they? I think one or two of them may have grown beards by then or flirted with beards. But then they go to Rishikesh. To Rishikesh. And they all have huge beards. Now there is an argument amongst 60s historians that people start to grow beards when they're also wearing kind of lacy shirts and big coats and they've got flowery scarves. And the beard is a way of getting away with all this yes
八字胡都非常少。大家都是光面。至于披头士，是奎师那（Maharishi）改变了他们吗？不，他们在去瑞诗凯诗之前就已经留起胡子了。他们是一年以后才去瑞诗凯诗的。那时他们还没留胡子，对吧？我想他们中有一两个人当时可能已经开始留胡子或者尝试过胡子了。但随后他们去了瑞诗凯诗。去了瑞诗凯诗。然后他们所有人都留了巨大的胡子。60年代的历史学家中有一种观点认为，人们开始留胡子的时候，往往也穿着那种花边衬衫和大衣，还围着花围巾。而胡子正是用来中和这些阴柔风气的一种方式——
you're masculizing yeah it's a reminder of your masculinity there's also a sense obviously that having the beards is a deliberately ironic nod back to victorian empire which is why it matches sergeant pepper and of course you could only do that once the empire had gone so maybe it's no coincidence it happens a few years after the empire has finally gone, because people can start joking about it. And having the beard or the Lord Kitchener style moustache or whatever is a way of doing that. I would associate the British empire with moustaches rather than beards, I think. That's maybe because you're thinking about later, don't you think? Yeah. It's Lord Kitchener who has the archetypal moustache, but he doesn't have a beard.
是的，你在强调男子气概。这是一种对你男子气概的提醒。当然，还有一种感觉，即留胡子是有意对维多利亚帝国进行一种具有讽刺意味的致敬，这就是为什么它与《佩珀军士》相呼应。当然，只有在帝国消亡之后，你才能这么做，所以这或许并非巧合——它发生在帝国最终消亡几年之后，因为人们开始以此开玩笑了。留着胡子或者基奇纳勋爵（Lord Kitchener）风格的八字胡等等，就是实现这一目的的一种方式。我觉得大英帝国更让人联想到八字胡而不是大胡子。这或许是因为你想到的是更后面的时期，你不觉得吗？对。基奇纳勋爵是典型的八字胡代表，但他没有大胡子。
Yeah, I guess you're right. Lord Kitchener is the archetypal moustache. You see, I'm wondering whether it's an Indian thing. It's a kind of yogi. Yeah. Because George Harrison keeps his beard. He does indeed. Yes. Longer, I think, than the other three Beatles. And he's the one who's really into transcendental meditation. Yeah. And Paul is the one who has it least long, I think. He has it on his thigh. Yeah. It's a good beard, but you know his heart's's not in it he's not a natural wearer of a beard i think it's fair to say the
对，我想你是对的。基奇纳勋爵是典型的八字胡化身。你看，我在想这是否与印度文化有关。这有点像瑜伽士的风格。对，因为乔治·哈里森保留了他的胡子。他确实留了。是的。我想他留的时间比其他三个披头士成员都要长。而且他是那个真正沉迷于超觉静坐的人。是的。保罗则是那个留得最短的人，我想。他只是偶尔留一下。对。这是个不错的胡子，但你知道他的心思并不在这上面，他天生就不是一个适合留胡子的人，我觉得这么说挺公允的。
funny thing is that i mentioned this earlier on this is also the heyday of mayor lord it's mustaches so beatles and other pop music magazines would advertise um facial hair that you could buy and stick onto your face so they would literally advertise it for 19 shillings so realistic they're almost undetectable and could be used time and time again says the advertising copy you would have to send them tom a little cutting of your hair so they could match it for color and then they would send you sideburns a mustache or a beard in that shade nice so we're thinking about for our next rest of history tour. Yeah. If we want to surprise people when we come on stage. So what about hipsters?
有趣的是——我刚才也提到了——这也是男士八字胡的全盛时期。所以披头士和其他流行音乐杂志会做广告推销你可以买来贴在脸上的假面部毛发。他们真的会以19先令的价格做广告，宣传其“逼真到几乎无法察觉，并且可以反复使用”，广告文案上是这么写的。你必须寄给他们一小撮你的头发，以便他们为你配好颜色，然后他们就会寄给你相应色调的鬓角、八字胡或大胡子。太棒了。所以在构思我们的下一场“历史余音”巡演时。如果我们想在登台时给人们一个惊喜的话。那么嬉皮士呢？
Is that fashion? Yeah, I think that's pure fashion. I tried to find some statistics. It's really hard to find these statistics, but just looking at photographs generally and things. What's striking to me is that, although the Beatles, you said the 60s is the golden age of the beard,
那是时尚吗？对，我认为那是纯粹的时尚。我试图找一些统计数据。真的很难找到这些数据，但仅从整体照片和其他资料来看。令我感到震惊的是，尽管披头士让人们觉得60年代是胡须的黄金时代，
there are very few bearded people in the 60s and 70s. If you think about public figures. Yeah, you're right. Fascinating. How many of them actually do have beards? I think beards, even in the 70s and the post Beatles heyday, are still ultimately seen as a little bit eccentric, a little bit bohemian. George Best has a beard. George Best has a beard, but that's part of George Best's decline, isn't it? That Best has become a bit dissipated, a bit eccentric. He puts himself above the team.
但在60年代和70年代，留胡子的人其实非常少。如果你想想那些公众人物。是的，你说得对。太迷人了。实际上到底有多少人留了胡子？我认为胡子，即便是在70年代和披头士热潮过去的鼎盛期，最终仍然被视为有点古怪，有点波希米亚风格。乔治·贝斯特（George Best）留了胡子。乔治·贝斯特留了胡子，但这其实是乔治·贝斯特走下坡路的一部分，对吧？说明贝斯特变得有点放纵，有点古怪。他把自己凌驾于球队之上。
He's spending all night with bottles of vodka and Miss World instead of thinking about tomorrow's match against Burnley. Practising free kicks and things. Exactly. In political cartoons in the 70s, beards are still, I hate to say it, Tom, but they're the badge of the freak. So the only people that have beards in... They're liberals, aren't they? Well, three kinds of people have beards in British political cartoons in the 70s. Members of the Liberal Party, members of the freak. So the only people that have beards in... They're liberals, aren't they? Well, three kinds of people have beards
他通宵达旦地喝伏特加、和世界小姐鬼混，而不是去考虑明天对阵伯恩利的比赛。练习任意球之类的。没错。在70年代的政治漫画中，胡子仍然——我真不想这么说，汤姆——但它们是怪咖的标志。所以唯一留胡子的人是……他们是自由党人，对吧？嗯，在70年代的英国政治漫画中，有三种人留胡子。自由党成员，爱尔兰共和军（IRA）成员，还有学校老师。有时这三种身份集于一身。
in British political cartoons of the 70s. Members of the Liberal Party, members of the IRA, and schoolteachers. Sometimes all three. Yes, I guess so. And actually,
是的，我想是的。说真的，
who's got the most famous beard in Britain today, would you say? Prince Harry. I think Prince Harry, maybe... For me, it's Jeremy Corbyn. Yeah.
如果要说当今英国谁拥有最著名的胡子，你会觉得是谁？哈里王子。我觉得哈里王子，也许——对我来说，是杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）。
I mean, Jeremy Corbyn, when he became leader of the Labour Party, people commented all the time about his beard. The Economist called it a counter-cultural badge of defiance against smooth-talking, smooth-faced capitalists. But you could say the same about Prince Harry. You could. Yeah, you could. So in 2017, there was a survey of newspaper comment pieces
我的意思是，当杰里米·科尔宾成为工党领袖时，人们一直在讨论他的胡子。《经济学人》称其为“对花言巧语、满面堆笑的资本家的一种反文化的挑衅标志”。但你对哈里王子也可以这么说。确实可以。对，完全可以。所以在2017年，曾有一项针对有关杰里米·科尔宾的报纸评论文章的调查，
about Jeremy Corbyn, and this survey found that 69% of them mentioned his beard. That's absolutely brilliant. Do you know what, Tom? I had a look myself. I've written six articles about Jeremy Corbyn that explicitly mentioned his beard. And how many, what proportion is that?
这项调查发现其中69%的文章都提到了他的胡子。这绝对太绝了。你知道吗，汤姆？我自己也查了一下。我写过六篇明确提到杰里米·科尔宾胡子的文章。那占比是多少？
I'm confident that I haven't overdone it, but I'd thrown it in a few times. It's generally, it's never meant kindly, to be honest. So this wasn't a policy that was dictated to you by the Daily Mail's editorial board? I never. You must mention Jeremy Corbyn's beard. The very thought of that is so shocking to me. And if anybody's listening from that organisation, they'll be shocked too, because they all know that that's absolutely not how
我确信我没有过度使用这个梗，不过确实随口提了那么好几次。而且通常来说，这从来都不是出于好意，老实说。所以这并不是《每日邮报》编辑部规定你必须遵守的方针？我从没有过。你必须提到杰里米·科尔宾的胡子。这种想法对我来说太令人震惊了。如果该机构有任何人听到这话，他们也会大吃一惊，因为他们都知道这绝对不是
newspapers work, Tom. Right. Okay. I just wondered whether there was an editorial policy. Absolutely not. But we should end by talking about, we should give our own views about whether or not men should have beards. So I drew up a list of three typical men without beards and three typical men with that might help you make up your mind, Tom.
报纸的工作方式，汤姆。好吧。我只是在想这是否算是一种编辑方针。绝对没有。但我们应该在结尾时聊聊——我们应该给出我们自己关于男人是否应该留胡子的看法。所以我列出了一份包含三个没有胡子的典型男人和三个留胡子的典型男人的清单，这或许能帮你下定决心，汤姆。
So Alexander the Great, no beard. Yeah. Henry V didn't have a beard. Yeah. And Nelson didn't have a beard. Yeah. And Nelson didn't have a beard. But then men with beards, the aforementioned Jeremy Corbyn has a beard. Prince Harry now has a beard. And the Yorkshire Ripper had a beard. So does that focus your mind at all?
亚历山大大帝，没胡子。对。亨利五世，没胡子。对。纳尔逊，没胡子。对。纳尔逊没胡子。但至于留胡子的男人：前面提到的杰里米·科尔宾留着胡子。哈里王子现在也留着胡子。还有约克郡开膛手也留着胡子。那么，这有让你重新权衡吗？
I mean, you could alternatively say that Caligula didn't have a beard. Yeah, that's true. Hitler didn't have a beard. He had a moustache. Come on. Grant Shapps, who greenlit the Stonehenge Tunnel. Pol Pot. He didn't have a beard. He had a moustache. Come on. Grant Shapps, who greenlit the Stonehenge Tunnel. Pol Pot. He didn't have a beard.
我的意思是，你也可以反过来举例说卡利古拉没胡子。对，这倒也是。希特勒没胡子。他留的是八字胡，得了吧。格兰特·沙普斯（Grant Shapps），批准了巨石阵隧道项目的人。波尔布特。他没胡子。他留的是八字胡，得了吧。格兰特·沙普斯，批准了巨石阵隧道项目的人。波尔布特。他没胡子。
Pol Pot was clean shaven. Yeah, Pol Pot. So, you know, they're all monsters from history. And then people who do have, I mean, God has a beard. Yeah. Sir Francis Drake. They're very similar. People that use God and Sir Francis Drake.
波尔布特刮得光溜溜的。对，波尔布特。所以你看，他们都是历史上的恶魔。而至于那些确实留胡子的人——我的意思是，上帝留着胡子。对。弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士。他们非常相似。把上帝和弗朗西斯·德雷克爵士归为一类的人。
The priestess of Athena who grew a beard whenever peril threatened. You know, I don't want to come to any firm and vast conclusions. Well, actually, do you know the person who really captures the complexity of this? It's Theo, our producer. Yes. Because we can never anticipate whether Theo will be bearded or not. Well, he had a Persian beard, as we said, on Friday. Yeah.
雅典娜的女祭司每当危险降临时就会长出胡子。你知道的，我不想得出任何坚定且宏大的结论。不过说实话，你知道谁真正捕捉到了这种复杂性吗？是提奥，我们的制作人。是的。因为我们永远无法预料提奥什么时候会留胡子，什么时候不会。嗯，正如我们周五所说，他当时留着波斯风格的胡子。对。
We're recording this on a Monday and it's completely gone. Yeah. It's very unsettling, isn't it? It is unsettling, yeah. It's very unsettling, isn't it? It is unsettling. Yeah. It's very unsettling. You've never been tempted to grow a beard?
我们是在周一录制这期节目的，而他的胡子已经完全刮干净了。对。这非常让人捉摸不定，对吧？确实很让人捉摸不定。对。这非常让人捉摸不定，对吧？确实很让人捉摸不定。对。这非常让人捉摸不定。你从来没有想过留胡子吗？
No. Because I think, I tell you what I think you would look like if you had a beard. You would look like a rascally ship's captain possibly involved in slaving
从来没有。因为我觉得——我告诉你如果你留了胡子你会长什么样。你会看起来像一个可能在维京时代
in the Viking era. Oh, in the Viking era? Yeah. Oh, brilliant. I'm well on for that. Monks and stuff you'd be trading in monks yeah you wouldn't look like a monk you'd look like somebody who who you weren't a full-blown warrior right but you dealt you know you would you would take the loot that
参与贩奴的无赖船长。哦，在维京时代？对。哦，太棒了。我完全可以接受这个形象。僧侣之类的人——你会在僧侣中做点买卖。对，你看起来不像个僧侣，你会看起来像那种——你不是一个正规的纯粹武士，
had been stolen by warriors from a monastery yeah you'd have a cackle an evil cackle yeah corrupt i think you would be corrupt and you'd probably be run through by the hero who would have been enslaved and would escape while you were trying to sell him. Alexander Skarsgård. He would kill you. He would run you through. And what sort of beard would you have? I think you would look like Roy Strong if you had a beard. Worst things to be.
但你专门处理——你会收下武士从修道院里偷来的战利品。是的，你会发出一阵狂笑，一阵邪恶的狂笑。对，腐败。我觉得你会是个腐败分子，而且很可能会被那个沦为奴隶、并在你试图卖掉他时逃脱的英雄一剑刺死。亚历山大·斯卡斯加德（Alexander Skarsgård）。他会杀了你。他会一剑刺穿你。那你觉得自己会留什么样式的胡子？我觉得如果你留胡子的话，你会长得像罗伊·斯特朗（Roy Strong）。世上最糟糕的长相。
Do you not think you'd go for a kind of pointed Van Dyke? I would go for it. I probably would go for a Van Dyke. Yeah. I'd try and go for Francis Drake, I think. Walter Raleigh. I've got the beard more of a medieval blacksmith. Yeah. Well, a ship's captain. Yeah. I'd try and go for Francis Drake, I think. Walter Raleigh. I've got the beard more of a medieval blacksmith. Yeah.
难道你不觉得你会留那种尖尖的范戴克式胡须（Van Dyke）吗？我会留的。我大概真的会留范戴克式胡须。对。我会试着留成弗朗西斯·德雷克那样的，我想。沃尔特·雷利。我觉得我的胡子更像中世纪的铁匠。对。嗯，一个船长。对。我会试着留成弗朗西斯·德雷克那样的，我想。沃尔特·雷利。我觉得我的胡子更像中世纪的铁匠。对。
Well, a ship's captain. Yeah. Well, that's kind. This has been revelatory. Top historical analysis. Very good. Yes. So the good news is there's been a lot to hear about men.
嗯，一个船长。对。好吧，这倒挺温和。这期节目真是大开眼界。顶级的历史分析。非常好。是的。所以好消息是，我们已经聊了很多关于男人的话题。
And I think, Tom, it's time that we had an episode about a woman, don't you? Yes. In fact, two. Two women in succession. Let's just go for it. Absolutely. Actually, three. So we could do Lee Miller, the great American photographer in the second world war.
而且我觉得，汤姆，是时候让我们做一期关于女性的节目了，你觉得呢？是的。事实上，连做两期。连续两期讲女性。我们就这么定了。绝对的。其实可以讲三期。比如我们可以讲李·米勒（Lee Miller），二战时期伟大的美国女摄影师。
Brilliant. And then we could do Evita. Great. Ava Perron. Why not? That'd be great. And then after that, perhaps we could do, I don't know, Boudicca. Brilliant.
太棒了。然后我们可以讲艾薇塔（Evita）。太棒了。阿根廷第一夫人伊娃·庇隆。为什么不呢？那会很棒。然后在这之后，也许我们可以讲——我不知道，布狄卡（Boudicca）。太棒了。
Let's do it. Let's do it. So if you want to hear those episodes early, you can do so by joining the, I'm not going to say how early because I don't want to overpromise, but you'll hear them before other people do, generally. But not Lee Miller, because Lee Miller might be coming on Thursday. You join the Rest Is History Club at therestishistory.com. And to be honest, not only do you get episodes early, you don't get the ads, but also you get the very high quality repart RT that we've been showcasing in this episode.
就这么办。就这么办。所以如果你想提前收听这些节目，你可以通过加入——我不会说具体提前多久，因为我不想过度承诺，但总的来说，你会比其他人更早听到。不过李·米勒的那期除外，因为李·米勒的节目可能周四就会上线。加入“历史余音俱乐部”，网址是 therestishistory.com。说实话，你不仅能提前听到节目、没有广告，还能欣赏到我们在本期节目中展示的高品质闲聊。
Isn't that true, Tom? Yeah, you absolutely do. So lots more beer chat to come in bonus episodes, no doubt, in the next few decades of The Rest Is History. And on that bombshell, Tom, I'm off for a shave. Bye bye. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
难道不是吗，汤姆？是的，绝对是这样的。所以在接下来的几十年里，《历史余音》的加更节目中无疑还会有更多的胡须八卦。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，我要去刮胡子了。拜拜。拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我们共同主持《娱乐余音》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及各种演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这背后的运作方式。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、获取加更节目以及提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。